jay carry a starting pitcher for the
cubs here tonight that's right it's jake
garrietto
swing and a miss struck him out and good
work to start for arietta
[Applause]
scherzer's ninth start of the year three
and two record 2.10 era
eighth lowest of the national league
oh look at josh harrison elevate
for the first down that ball
was crushed
slider down strikeout number 69
jim bunning is only two away as max
like arrieta with a strikeout works a
one two three first
jake deals check swing he went too far
it's a strikeout got him to bite and a
breaking ball in the dirt
and his second punch out of the night
one away
and with two down and two aboard here is
nicole horner
the o2 in the air that might find a home
out in right
center and it does buddy around thirty's
in the score
and here's racing for the plate the
throw
it is out tried to catch him napping
and steal the run but in that spot
he's cut down cubs though
nico horner an rbi single it's one
nothing
on a pitch up robles takes it well and
deep the other way
that ball is going to bounce up and hit
the basket
and go over the basket into the
bleachers one away in a man at second
trey turner now that paul gets some
plate and it's a base hit up the middle
rubles speeding around third and trey
turner
after looking not so great for one at
bat
two-thirds of another delivers rbi
number 23 and the nats are back even
he got a fastball base hit turner will
have to stop but third he had to hold up
with two defenders near him
and the nats have three consecutive hits
three straight hits for washington they
have tied the game they are threatening
to take their first lead of the series
here's josh bell
that one back to the barrier it pinballs
around turner scores
2-1 nets soto to second
here's a line drive to right hayward
coming on and jason makes the catch
that is right in there max scherzer two
strikeouts
keep it here one on one out
swan gonna miss on a big slider and for
max scherzer third of the night
and he ties the great jim bunning
swing and a miss and now he's alone
in 19th place on the all-time list max
three strikeouts around the walk
a long no contact inning that's lead
into the middle innings
hello ian mike's up
there's no anthony on my side of the
infield that's like half of it
i don't get any hits because i have a
long pants on yeah kyle
you could have had it i'm mic'd up if
you want to say something really funny
you're speedy though you look great
2-2 close enough
and gomes will line an extra base hit
into that deep right-field corner
john gomes the other way giving max and
robles an rbi
opportunity here top of the fourth
row blaze hooks one left field corner
it's another double for victor
well maybe not he fell down and oh no
victor robles is hurt gets back to the
bag
and he grabs the right ankle he rolled
it
a little bit as he's rounding the base
where's three-quarter cleats so he
doesn't have that ankle protection
the good news he popped up and he's
walking on it
andrew stevenson if needed stretching
davey wants to be careful so victor sold
him on the fact that he can stay in the
game
nice
insurers are not wasting any time
disposing of
pj's major league debut at that
strikeout number five two down
swinging a miss on a big hook max erzer
pulls one more trick out of his bag
six k's through four
juan soto soto is one for two
got a breaking ball it's high in the
year to right
look at it fly see you
later it's the nationals four the cubs
won
juan soto was all over it drops to the
knee
one and two to nico horner no way to
reach that
three swinging strikeouts in a row max
is stalking
and he has seven on the game
broken bad out towards center to base
hit
and jake garrieta his first knock of the
season
[Applause]
on the ground that's a base hit into
left field
he just punched it the other way
and now two aboard with one out bryant
waits
sures are deals good
take wow bases are loaded for ian happ
just one away here in the bottom half of
the fifth and eighth
half weights
in the air center field that won't sink
in and it falls for a hit
in the
peterson half got enough of it and
dumped it into center in the cubs
and a run it's 4-2
[Applause]
swing and a miss did he go yes he did
yes she did
well that's that's what happens when you
stare at max like that you look at the
green eye instead of the brown eye
go back to the dugout with the punch out
popped him up victor robles
camping and after all that the cubs get
one run
trey turner swinging a miss ball goes
off at an
angle and trey turner has beaten the
throw which goes into right field
is trey turner going to be called out
for running in the baseline
or out of the baseline it's amazing how
much this gets called
and here goes davey again with one of
these
and he's just been thrown out of the
game because he stepped onto the field
of play
and showed the umpire what actually
happened and he's taken
he's going to go lloyd mcclendon and
take first base
out of the ground memories of game six
from the world series
give the groundskeeper the hand that's
[Music]
right
jordan mercer at third on the double
switch bats eighth
and on the first pitch stevenson
he's got it andrew stevenson in
full run playing a power hitter deep
all right so last chance for the cubs
here one down ninth inning javier baez
the batter
in the air left field that one back
one is gone
up comes within one now homer to make it
a one-run
game ryan at second he's the tying run
two outs three and
with a lot of suspense puts this one
away
and the nats win it 4-3